we're going to continue our look at the
midterm elections this morning with the
state of the economy the top issue for
voters right now it seems one big reason
for this year's Rising inflation gas
prices the national average for a gallon
of regular is 3.85 now that's down from
last week but it's up from a month ago
Republicans think the economy is a
winning issue for them while the Biden
Administration wants to show it's
working to bring the prices down Wichita
Zhang is at the White House she's always
a winner Ouija before you get started I
have to say welcome back you got a new
baby in the house we are so glad that
you're here first day back from baby
leave yeah welcome back welcome back you
guys thank you so much I missed you and
I feel like it just happened because I
just saw you at the White House
Correspondents Dinner yes the next
morning guess who went into labor this
one
[Laughter]
in on the action so here we are and you
know what we were talking about back
then gas prices gas prices
here we are so today the president is
going to announce another 15 million
barrels of oil released from the
Strategic petroleum Reserve but that's
not exactly new this is the last of the
180 million barrels that he already
authorized to sell back in March when
gas prices started soaring as a result
of the war in Ukraine the move is not
expected to make a significant
difference at the pumps though
especially since OPEC just announced
this month that it would cut oil
production by up to 2 million barrels a
day the president will also detail plans
to repurchase and replenish the
Strategic Reserve when the price of oil
drops to 67 to 72 dollars a barrel
compared to the 85 dollars it is right
now now senior Administration officials
say the president is prepared to
authorize even more oil be released from
the national stockpile with just about
three weeks left to go before the
midterms they are really hoping that
this may message resonates with voters
that they are doing everything that they
can but the fact is those prices are
climbing
so is the President we should doing
anything else to entice voters as we get
ready to go to polls
yes Gail he is vowing to make abortion
rights the top priority for him next
year if Democrats maintain control of
Congress he is warning people that that
is on the ballot he's urging voters to
factor in the Supreme Court's decision
to overturn Roe v Wade the president and
other Democrats running for Senate are
pushing to change the filibuster to
codify abortion rights but unless
Democrats win a 60-seat majority in the
Senate they will not have the votes to
do that Gail all right all right wija
Jack and Frankie's mom that first day
back is always fun getting back up on
that bicycle but you certainly know what
you're doing really good to see you
thanks a lot thanks